alfred castillo here the sprinkler
warehouse pro i wanted to do a quick
little video here on how to use quick
lock fittings quick lock fittings come
in couplers tees elbows plugs and
adapters right here is a quick lock
coupling 40.94 OD that's 3/4 inch tubing
let's attach it unscrew the nut here to
expose the barbed the first thing you'll
probably notice is that the nut turns
opposite of what you'd expect rock the
tube back and forth to wiggle it on now
tighten up the nut
[Music]
these are removable and reusable when
you get ready to remove it just reverse
the process
[Music]
now these are for drip only operating
pressure is 45 psi max so that's how you
use quick lock remember sprinkler
warehouse has everything for your
irrigation needs so that your trees
lawns flowerbeds and gardens are lush
and beautiful and if you have any
questions about our products chat with
one of our superb customer service
agents on sprinkler warehouse.com they
really know their stuff and they'll get
you squared away please subscribe to our
YouTube channel to get the most out of
our user-friendly shop and compare Web
Store for sprinkler warehouse
I'm alfred castillo your sprinkler
warehouse pro
[Music]